se trata del mayor número de contagios
por kobe 19 en un día desde que se
levantó el confinamiento en este país el
pasado 11 de mayo en las últimas 24
horas casi 5000 personas se contagiaron
del virus en este país lo que hace que
la población se pregunte y también las
autoridades si se trata de la esperada
segunda ola de la pandemia según en la
combe ella es la jefa de los servicios
de enfermedades infecciosas del hospital
san antón en parís esa segunda ola ya
llegó a fines de julio con los parisinos
que regresaron de sus vacaciones de
verano no tienen nada que ver con lo que
vivimos en marzo y abril y efectivamente
ha aumentado las hospitalizaciones pero
según ella los centros de salud están
mejor preparados por lo que no ha habido
saturación en los servicios de
reanimación ya que son otros los
protocolos que están siguiendo
completamente distintas la opinión del
presidente del consejo científico
francés jean françois delfraissy
entrevistado por la radio france-info a
su juicio estos últimos casos de kobe 19
pertenecen todavía a la
y se dan porque las personas no respetan
las medidas de distancia social en
regiones sobre todo donde la enfermedad
no había llegado y por eso llama los
franceses a respetar esas medidas ya que
no hay ni vacuna ni remedio contra la
enfermedad y recuerda que los afectados
de estas últimas contaminaciones son
sobre todo jóvenes que no respetan las
medidas barrera como se le conoce aquí
en francia y pone el ejemplo de regiones
como la mañana aquí en francia la guyana
francesa o barcelona que supieron con
esas medidas controlar los rebrotes